- Thanks, man.
Keep em coming.
- Thanks.
(bottles clinking)
- See, all these posters on
the walls were from shows.
I mean, I'm not
having to telling you.
You know this.
- Dude, we're in a show
together right there.
- [Man 1] That one.
- [Man 2] Jerks of Warp Speed
- [Man 1] Jerks of Warp Speed
- Yeah, and I'm in this one
here, Business as Unusual.
- Ah, these walls could talk.
I once saw a cock fight
in the back there.
Really crazy.
- You saw a cock fight?
- Right in the back.
- They don't do
cock fights here.
- Oh
- Maybe I was just watching
two chickens fight then.
- Mmm.
- Huh, you know it's funny.
I had my 21st birthday--
- Yeah
- at midnight this bar.
- I was there.
I'm older than you--
- Yo, that's, yeah it's a fact
- so I was there.
- So yeah, you were
present for all of my--
What, what are you doing?
- What are you even doing?
- What the hell are you doing?
- You said keep em coming.
- Yeah, obviously wait till
we're done with these ones.
- Like when we're
done with these--
- Then you bring other one.
- You gotta be more specific--
- No, this is a human concept
- Really?
- of like, the one of them put
my finishes and once more--
- It's the first time this
has ever been a problem.
- Yeah
- Guys, just finish the beers,
and I'll keep em coming then.
- It's just gonna get warm.
- I'll drink em.
I'm fine to drink em.
- I'm gonna drink em.
I mean, I have to technically.
- Yeah